[Music]
it never changes
my wife
hi
you guys must be new to town right new
to town but not new to the country we
just moved from California we speak
English oh that's wonderful
um we're just curious
um are you Chinese
yes oh great
oh we just wondered uh if you wouldn't
mind if your daughter played with our
daughter
why our daughter oh we just we just saw
Audrey
[Music]
you want to play slide
haha
slides off limits to Ching Chong's
do you want to be best friends
[Music]
my grandpa's name is Joe just like my
dad's he loves model trains and he has a
gout why don't you look like your family
because I'm adopted from China that's
why I have a birth mom I would be so mad
if my parents gave me up did you do
something her mom didn't water obviously
[Music]
you know what everyone else you
don't have to prove anything to these
losers
[Music]
taking the rain
lean on each other
[Music]